[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique
gros plan aujourd'hui sur la ruralité le
mouvement des gilet jaune fait parler de
nos campagnes et la semaine dernière le
congrès des maires s'est achevée à paris
on n'y a vu et entendu la grogne des
élus de terrain
d'ailleurs à cette occasion un chiffre a
été publié en 2020 un maire sur deux ne
se représentera pas ce sondage a été
réalisé par le cevipof
l'institut de sciences po paris avec la
mf l'association des maires de france
alors justement pour parler de ce
malaise chez les mères de mer euros sur
le plateau tout d'abord christelle
clément lé maire de j en haute saône
elle est également vice-présidente de
l'association des maires ruraux de ce
département
et puis face à l grégoire durant il est
maire de dampierre dampierre dans le
jura il est également secrétaire général
de l'association des maires du jura
n'oubliez pas que grâce à twitter vous
pouvez commenter réagir cette émission
avec le hashtag dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
alors je me tourne tout d'abord vers la
dame de cette assistance christelle
clément vous êtes maire de ji ont 100
habitants vous êtes maire depuis 2008
est-ce que vous avez le blues non je
n'ai pas le blues
la fonction est parfois difficile on
peut ressentir une certaine lassitude
mais toute façon je ne dirais que
globalement non je n'ai pas le blues
il ya tellement de belles choses à faire
quand on est élu que non vous vous
présentez dans 18 mois
je ne sais pas encore alors grégoire
durant vous vous êtes maire depuis 2009
vous avez succédé au maire élu qui est
décédé en cours de mandat
dampierre sait tous 100 habitants alors
vous est-ce que vous représentez non
vous allez le blues c'est pas le blues
mais voilà casser le titre d'émission
mais je casse peut-être pas le cas des
missions en tout cas je suis élu depuis
2001 et aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
l'intention de me représenter en 2020 je
pense que j'ai fait déjà pas mal de
choses sur la commune et donc je
souhaite passer le relais à d'autres
personnes sans avoir totalement de blues
alors vous étiez au congrès des maires à
paris la semaine dernière comme tous les
ans vous êtes un fan je suis un fan j'ai
un avis je suis un habitué depuis 2010
depuis que j'ai pris mes fonctions j'ai
pris l'habitude de me rendre au congrès
pour diffère du fer ce raison et je vous
disais que c'était un peu une thérapie
de groupe
alors c'est un peu une thérapie de
groupe ça permet aussi un petit peu de
souffle et un moment de récréation et
puis ça permet aussi de côtoyer divers
maires de toute la france avec qui on
peut partager un certain nombre
d'expériences et donc c'est très
intéressant pour moi
alors non seulement vous étiez au
congrès mais vous étiez également parmi
les vannes de happy few vip rva very
important de personnes pour ceux qui
parlent pas anglais donc les 2000 reçu
par emmanuel macron à l'elysée oui vous
a convaincu séduit l'emballé pas
convaincu ni séduit les emballer c'est
vrai que j'ai répondu à son invitation
l'année dernière j'avais invité je
n'avais pas pu me rendre parce que
l'invitation avait été très tardive qui
était aussi le cas cette année là pour
tenter un esprit républicain quand le
président nous invite on se rend à
l'elysée j'ai pas boudé l'invitation et
je l'écoutais gérer de façon très
républicaine mais sans conviction
particulière lors le mandat de maire et
même celui d'adjoint devient de plus en
plus difficiles à exister exercer
pourquoi
quelles sont les difficultés auxquelles
sont confrontés les élus des petites
communes direction vit à fond ou le
maire gérard quêter sait déjà qu'il va
jeter l éponge reportage emmanuel rivals
1 et david martin au coeur de la vallée
de la loue via france 700 habitants une
image de tranquillité presque parfaite
mais en prêtant bien l'oreille un autre
son se détache
le blues de l'équipe municipale
aujourd'hui et je vais quitter la
fonction avec soulagement
c'est toute la différence entre le début
du mandat du monde que chacun autour de
cet homme les 14 conseillers se pose la
question de savoir qu'est ce qu'on fait
en 2020 à quoi on sert des entrées des
chaises vides
bientôt dans les mairies certains y
pensent le motif de leur colère
l'intercommunalité un changement
d'échelle radical pour ces élus on
n'arrivait toujours pas à en faire un
bouquet communauté de communes auch peu
con mais en étaient 26 27
maintenant les 78 79 qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse pas possible on peut
mettre chez nous pour comprendre les
enjeux de l'intercommunalité
ces élus nous emmène à la station de
pompage le trésor de la commune la
gestion de l'eau va bientôt leur
échapper pourtant cette proximité a
largement fait ses preuves
ce qu'on craint essentiellement c'est la
réactivité et bernard suit au jour le
jour
l'eau distribuée les fuites cette année
avec la sécheresse on a dû réparer
quinzaine de fuite le bureau de poste
étaient promis à la fermeture le guichet
désormais hébergés par la mairie
autant d'actions menées avec des moyens
financiers de moins en moins certain
le bonheur de la dgf la dotation
générale de fonctionnement d'un bonheur
très limité et en régression
on est passé de 160 milles à 130000
euros entre 2014 et 2018
c'est énorme c'est énorme parce qu'on ne
peut pas la compenser par les taxes
d'habitation qui vont disparaître
pour toutes ces raisons aujourd'hui en
france la moitié des mères envisage
d'abandonner leurs fonctions à la fin de
leur mandat
[Musique]
christine clément est ce que vous vous
retrouvez dans ce reportage
setc les transferts de compétences à
l'intercommunalité est effectivement une
des raisons principales pour lesquelles
les maires ne se représente pas en 2020
vous retrouvez également
oui c'est assez représentatif de ce que
ressentent un certain nombre d'élus
d'élus locaux et notamment l'usure de
demander avec la complexité qui
s'accroît du rangement alors je vous
parlais d'un sondage tout à l'heure le
motifs pour lesquels les maires ne se
représente pas dans 18 mois
or plusieurs réponses étaient possibles
c'est tout d'abord bon pour se consacrer
à leur vie personnelle et familiale
après ceux qui considèrent c'est ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que le
devoir civique est remplie il faut
passer la main à d'autres
après c'est l'exigence des administrés
et puis en ensuite c'est parce qu'il ya
moins de moyens financiers vie
personnelle et familiale vous c'est
important et c'est important je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure depuis 2001 être élu
c'est un sacrifice et c'est vrai qu'on
met de côté la vie familiale et on est
un petit peu égoïste dans nos colonnes a
une qui est contente quand vous annoncer
officiellement que vous vous représenter
par une quête très très contente et qui
sait contre les mois pour pas dire
elle compte les mois carrément mulhouse
oui oui je crois que là elle a envie de
que ce mandat s'arrête pour qu'on
retrouve un peu de sérénité
alors quand on a présenté cette émission
ensemble vous m'avez dit quand même que
ce qui était super dur c'est le
troisième motif c'est l'exigence des
administrés alors qu'est ce qui a changé
dans la relation entre le maire et ses
administrés dans les communes rurales
je crois que ce qui a beaucoup changé en
fait c'est le fait que le maire
c'est le premier interlocuteur que
l'administré a finalement en face de lui
quasiment au quotidien nous donne aux
petites communes de toute façon on est
forcément toujours au contact des
habitants
donc quand quelque chose ne va pas c'est
la première personne à qui l'administré
va en parler ce qui fait que
eh bien il ya une accumulation
effectivement 2 2
alors deux plateaux ou d'exigences plus
ou moins justifiées parfois mais en tout
cas qui s'accumulent je trouve sur le
maire alors il ya un sociologue qui
disait qu'il n'y a plus une relation de
citoyens contribuables
donc d'un côté m il ya une relation
maintenant de contribuables à
fournisseurs de services est ce que vous
trouvez que cette expression est juste
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'exigence
il ya beaucoup de gens considèrent
souvent qu'on a beaucoup de droits par
contre la question de quel devoir on à
anvers envers le collectif voilà
indépendamment de la question de la
collectivité est souvent un peu plus
loin loin loin est aperçu oui c'est vrai
que les nos citoyens sont exigeants et
puis la société a évolué donc ils ont
ils ont les moyens d'être exigeants ils
peuvent re se confronter à ce qu'ils
voient autour d'eux dans les zones
urbaines et puis ils demandent souvent
les mêmes services ou parliez de service
donc c'est vrai qu'ils sont demandeurs
de ces services y compris en ruralité
est un peu comme en ville ils veulent la
même chose qu'en ville où près louis ou
alors peut-être pas tout à fait mais ils
veulent les mêmes services parce qu'ils
ont quasiment pour la plupart le même
style de vie qu'en ville
ils veulent l'internet ils veulent des
crèches qui veulent des services et
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de la
faire comprendre que en campagne on ne
peut pas immédiatement leur répondre à
toutes leurs exigences donc ça c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué et puis je suis d'accord avec
ma collègue c'est que le maire étant le
premier interlocuteur est lurons
cristallise un peu toutes les
frustrations que ce soit de notre
compétence ou pas de notre compétence on
a parfois des reproches et on commence
par leur dit mais vous savez ça ce n'est
pas de notre rôle ce n'est pas de notre
compétence
il faudrait aller voir quelqu'un d'autre
alors ils le comprennent parfois mais en
tout cas nous on est vraiment le
réceptacle de de ces deux de ses
exigences et c'est parfois un petit peu
compliqué alors se battent pour des
services vous vous l'avez fait en tant
que maire vous êtes descendus dans la
rue pour sauver votre trésorerie en juin
dernier
alors vous n'aviez pas de gilet jaune à
mais vous aviez une écharpe tricolore
déjà ça a marché
ben c'est ça a marché c'est la deuxième
fois c'est à dire c'est la deuxième fois
effectivement qu'on va où il dit c'est
la population et les élus
jusque là les administrés ont suivi les
administrés ont suivi
à la fois par des pétitions ou par le
fait d'être présent sur un rassemblement
qu'on avait organisé et c'était la
deuxième fois et pour la deuxième fois
on a eu une réponse de l'administration
nous informant du maintien de trésorerie
alors le président national de laisse
donc de l'association des maires ruraux
de france qui s'appelle vanik berberian
avait dit il craignait lui que le jour
du congrès des maires à paris
il est certains maires qui arrivent avec
des gilet jaune vous avez été sur le
point de mettre des gilet jaune ou pas
alors pas forcément de mettre le gilet
jaune parce que je pense qu'on peut
exprimer aussi la défense de la ruralité
ou du territoire rural d'une autre
manière qu'avec lui gilet jaune
je n'y allais dire notre combat au
quotidien je pense qu'effectivement sans
avoir de gilet jaune
on essaie aussi de faire en sorte que
cette ruralité elle existe enfin de la
même manière qu'on peut avoir en ville
donc il n'y a pas forcément besoin de le
revêtir ce gilet jaune
mais malgré tout les gilet jaune vous en
avez vu dans votre secteur agit oui on a
eu une action
donc le 17 novembre le premier sur la
première action organisée on a eu une
action qui a mobilisé beaucoup et qui
s'est fait je trouve enfin la de manière
très calme et sereine pour effectivement
marqué les difficultés qu'on a dans les
territoires ruraux
vous aussi vous avez vu des gis les
jeunes que vous vous êtes sur une
ancienne nationale oui tout à fait côté
du rond point de l'autoroute
oui le rond point avant chaud juste la
commune qui est juste après dampierre il
ya eu un mouvement le 17 novembre qui
c'est qui s'est perpétuée qui continue
encore un petit peu
et puis il y en a un peu plus loin dans
le temps durs à rochefort où là aussi
garder le des actions qui ont été menées
parce que je crois que les citoyens en
ont un petit peu marre de ces citoyens
de la périphérie et des campagnes où on
va les entendre justement parce que donc
depuis plus de sommes dues depuis plus
de deux semaines les gilet jaune se font
entendre dans toute la france en force
côté aussi ils sont très actifs
voici ce qu'ils disent propos recueillis
aux quatre coins de la région
moi je suis retraité j'ai du mal à finir
la fin de mort c'est le ras bol général
là ça va rester je pense courant la
semaine prochaine mais c'est faux on
restera là on sera toujours là on sera
là encore on
criera toujours au secours parce qu'on
en a ras-le-bol faible pour nos enfants
nos petits enfants
et puis que la vie c'est un petit peu
meilleure ce que toujours payé travail
moi j'ai travaillé toute ma vie je suis
en retraite et donc on me pique encore
sur ma retraite j'irai glaire sur presse
à commande numérique et je travaille de
nuit pour 1300 euros de salaire voilà et
les taxe qu'on a
donc nous nous ronge la vie quoi on se
bat aussi bien pour avoir une vie un peu
meilleure que moi et ma femme on est
deux vaches à lait et tous les gens qui
sont là sont des vaches à lait donc il
ya un moment donné qu'ils pensent à nous
un petit peu on ne monte pas grand chose
on demande de vivre décemment d'avoir ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir vivre pour
pouvoir s'en sortir c'est tout y a pas
de politique ses citoyens c'est on ne
tient pas voyez on n'a pas marqué cgt
pour marquer partie droite parti de
gauche y'a rien c'est on est tous
solidaires
c'est pour nous pour nos enfants
là c'est le peuple qui se lève il faut
vraiment que monsieur macron fasse
quelque chose là on peut plus vivre on
est pris à la gorge
il faut qu'on rachète des voitures mais
avec quoi cette troll un peu plus un peu
plus on est surtaxé c'est ça ma
condition est surtaxée il faut arrêter
les gens ils galèrent tous à pourvoir
faire la fin du mois un gars qui vivent
avec leur salaire y verra bien avec 8
200 euros tu pourras pas loin je n'irai
pas paris parce que ma mon combat il est
ici pour le milieu rural pour tous les
problèmes qui a gardé le dessus de votre
petit territoire
on est déterminés on lâchera pas macron
devra lâcher il ya du monde derrière il
ya du monde on dit donc cette france qui
porte les gie des jeunes aujourd'hui
c'est la france de la ruralité de la
périphérie des zones de pavillon est-ce
que c'est donc des administrés à vous
oui si on reconnaît dans les témoignages
qui ont été dans ce reportage des
administrés de nos territoires qui
effectivement où un certain nombre de
pressions ont des dépenses auxquelles
ils ont du mal à faire face et dampierre
ses 25 kilomètres de dole et 25 km de
besançon juste au milieu et 80% des
habitants de dampierre travail sur
besançon donc ont des frais de transport
est aujourd'hui effectivement c'est des
frais qui s'ajoute à l'augmentation des
impôts pour certains augmentent donc
vous comprenez tout à fait vous pourriez
presque les rejoindre 1,15 gilet jaune
en jeu pourraient les rejoindre tout à
fait bon après c'est un mouvement qui
s'est dit apolitique et donc pour des
raisons je veux dire pour les laisser
s'exprimer de façon totalement
apolitique et qu'on nous accuse pas de
récupérer effectivement pour x raisons
mais effectivement c'est on comprend
tout à fait et par rapport à ce que
c'est ma collègue tout à l'heure je
crois que les petites communes rurales
rurales qui sont aussi confrontés à de
plus en plus de pression d'exigence et
de moins en moins de dotations un petit
peu comme comme ses administrés en fait
on est presque les gilet jaune des
collectivités territoriales on a du mal
à un moment donné a joint les do we vous
pensez aussi que exactement enfin
comment comment on fait pour que la
ruralité vives 6
on n'a pas ces moyens de transport qui
aujourd'hui pose enfin sur le fond du
problème
les services de transport public ou
commun dont on nous parle en nous disant
il faut utiliser les services de
transport en commun alors au mieux il
existe en étant inadapté au pire il
n'existe pas du tout le transport en
commun il ya des arrêts dans les gares
qui sont supprimés donc comment au
niveau de la ruralité on peut
aujourd'hui dire à la population
utiliser les transports en commun alors
le grand le grand mot c'est
l'intercommunalité on vous a dit
regrouper vous pour mettre ensemble vos
moyens pour être plus efficace par
exemple donc on va voir un chiffre en
intercommunalité 80% des maires de
france jusque l'intercommunalité a une
influence sur sa commune et 75% des
trois cas jusque cette influence est
négative
on l'a vu dans le reportage tout à
l'heure donc il ya un des adjoints de
vie afin qu'ils disaient on n'est plus
maître chez nous je vous ai vu opiné du
chef et sourire parce que c'est ce que
vous pensez oui parce que c'est en fait
alors ce que je pense ou en tout cas ce
que pensent la plupart des élus encore
une fois des petites communes rurales
c'est le fait de se sentir dépossédés de
la vie au quotidien parce que comme le
disait effectivement mon collègue tout à
l'heure l'administré c'est le maire qui
va voir quelle que soit en fait
finalement être le député qui fait les
lois alors on est d'accord
bon alors le député mais même le
président de la communauté de communes
enfin cesser voilà c'est en général
quelqu'un qui est pas forcément
identifiés sur le territoire et donc on
va voir le maire alors là terrier encore
vous vous avez des intercoms qu'ils sont
et j'allais dire à tes à taille humaine
puisque lé monde j -c 25 communes 6300
genève et le temps et vous jura nord ces
28 communes et 15000 habitants
c'est encore des taille humaine oui des
tailles humaines et selon les
intercommunalités ou selon la
gouvernance dans les intercommunalités
la perception de l'intercommunalité par
l'élu en fait par le maire souvent elle
n'est pas la même c'est à dire que quand
le maire se sent encore impliqué dans
les décisions de l'intercommunalité
il a une perception de
l'intercommunalité qui est peut-être un
peu moins négative je peux pas dire
quelles alors certains ont quand même
une perception positive mais après ce
qui est notamment
défendu par l'association des maires
ruraux au niveau national c'est la
question de l'intercommunalité choisi
c'est à dire que en finir une bonne fois
pour toutes avec le transfert de
compétences automatique alors c'est vrai
que c'est des termes peut-être plus
d'exemples on a vu sur vie à fond c'est
l'eau et l'assainissement et la ceni
vous a pas demandé la vôtre à gand c'est
à dire c'est ça aussi et surtout des
dates butoir pour le faire et qui
étaient parfois très très rapide
effectivement là on et non plus sur
l'intercommunalité choisi avec des
compétences choisies qu'on construit
petit à petit on est sur quelque chose
qui nous force à un petit peu la main et
c'est compliqué plus une taille
d'intercommunalité qui a été basée
simplement sur un chiffre de population
et on a vu des intercommunautés secret
avec des territoires qui n'était pas
forcément le cas vais pas l'habitude de
fonctionner ensemble donc ces gens là
c'est pas forcément cohérent c'est
incohérent on parlait de bassin de vie
je pense qu'il ya plein d'exemples où le
bassin de vie n'est finalement pas si
bien respecter respecter que ça alors
vous parlez donc de perte d'autonomie
par rapport à l'intercommunalité et
autres perte d'autonomie aussi c'est la
taxe d'habitation puisque lll va être
donc là elle est diminuée pour certains
de vos administrés elle va être
supprimée dans trois ans concrètement
chez vous à dampierre ça a donné quoi
alors bah ça va être la première année
donc ça déjà nous sur dampierre donc on
n'a plus les moyens d'avoir ce levier de
recettes un d'augmenter la taxe
d'habitation ou de palau que les élus
ils aiment bien voir ça quand même
pour savoir sur quoi ils peuvent compter
bien sûr ça nous donne surtout des
perspectives et si on investit un peu
plus on sait qu'on va voir on va pouvoir
avoir un levier et surtout ça nous donne
un lien direct avec la population
puisque on sait leur rendre des comptes
on leur dit on investit on va sans doute
augmenter les impôts où on décide de ne
pas augmenter les impôts et donc du coup
de baisser un petit peu évolué ça
c'était un lien direct avec les
habitants on ne l'aura plus ça sera
simplement quelque chose qui nous sera
compensée et qui est totalement figée
pour les trois années à venir
d'ailleurs on va voir encore une
infographie quand il ya moins d'argent
46% des mets reportent leurs
investissements plutôt que de réduire
les services augmenter l'impôt ou encore
l'endettement
vous aussi vous voyez la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation avec un peu
d'inquiétude
oui avec beaucoup d'inquiétude parce que
enfin pour moi la première inquiétude
c'est la perte d'autonomie comme
mon collègue vient de le dire la perte
d'autonomie de la collectivité
on est on est dans une fonction où
effectivement on a à rendre des comptes
à notre population
mais on peut facilement rendre des
comptes quand on s'est expliqué sur la
base de l'impôt et notamment de la taxe
d'habitation quels investissements quels
services on met en face quand on nous
dit on va alors on va compenser c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui inquiétude c'est
peut-être pas le terme parce qu'on nous
a dit moi je dirais plutôt que j'attends
de voir
c'est à dire qu'on nous a dit qu'on
allait compenser à l'euro près mais
alors quid des évolutions alors allah ou
alors ça veut dire à l'euro près
j'explique ça veut dire que l'état va
compenser exactement la même somme mais
ça met à un instant t
sans tenir compte ni de l'inflation ni
le plein des deux lacs de man ray hé hé
hé on n'a plus ce levier qui aujourd'hui
enfin il thé à la main de la
collectivité qui décidez alors
d'augmenter mais aussi qu'ils pouvaient
décider de diminuer c'était plus rare 1
ça arrive et ça arrive et ça arrive et
notamment par rapport à
l'intercommunalité ou quand il y avait
un choix qui a été fait à
l'intercommunalité sur l'imposition des
collectivités donc des communes jouer le
jeu de baisser
en contrepartie l'augmentation qui
pouvait y avoir sur l'intercommunalité
donc ça veut dire que ce levier là il
existe plus du tout et que on a quelque
part moi j'ai l'impression
on est quelque part mis sous tutelle
c'est à dire qu'on nous dit on va vous
donner de l'argent vous essayez de faire
fonctionner au mieux alors on reçoit des
courriers très rassurants de la part du
président de la république sur le grand
rôle du maire dans une commune mais
quels sont les actes derrière pour
effectivement montré ce qui est écrit
dont on entendait tout à l'heure dans le
reportage un élu qui disait on se
demande à quoi on sert ce c'est ça votre
sentiment
oui en effectivement on se pose la
question de la gouvernance et encore une
fois les l'intercommunalité de transfert
de compétences il peut avoir il peut
être légitime
une compétence elle peut avoir sa
pertinence en changeant de taille
effectivement mais malgré tout le lien
politique qu'on a avec l'usagé la
gouvernance et la proximité qu'on a un
usager on le perd dans ces
intercommunalités qui des fois sont un
petit peu le dit fort vous vous sentez
abandonnés par l'état
oui on sent surtout mis sous tutelle
avec avec un discours un peu
moralisateur ou on doit participer à
l'effort surtout conseiller les parents
faut pas dépenser trop faut pas dépenser
trop alors qu'on ait enfin cette débat
qu'on entend souvent les communes on
équilibre nos budgets on peut avoir de
l'endettement du surendettement mais là
on a un état qui nous qui nous met des
règles très drastiques et qu'ils nous
considèrent pas forcément comme des
collectivités autonomes
on veut garder cette autonomie des
collectivités est-ce que vous pensez que
vous administrez comprennent donc que
vous êtes un peu coincé entre l'enclume
et le marteau
certains comprennent bon après ça c'est
notre rôle de dé lui aussi leurs fesses
de tout vous devez faire de la pédagogie
oui mais moi je pense que ça fait partie
du rôle de maire parce que effectivement
si on veut recréer de la citoyenneté
c'est à nous qui sommes les premiers les
premiers élus les premiers ne l'est plus
c'est à dire accessible de ré expliquer
les enjeux d'une collectivité de
respecter nos compétences ce qu'on peut
faire on peut faire les administrés ne
comprenne c'est pas des personnes qui
sont aussi du côté jean comprennent
aussi oui mais je crois qu'on a un rôle
important de pédagogie enfin s'il ya un
taux de participation sur les élections
municipales et si le maire est toujours
les lieux préférés des français là ça
c'est bien parce qu'il y avait un lien
du hawkeye et voilà c'est parce qu'il ya
un lien fort avec les administrés donc
effectivement ça fait partie de notre
fonction aussi que d'expliquer
enfin voilà la manière dont ça se passe
pour les collectivités alors qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire un statut de l'élu
parce que je précise que tous les deux
vous travaillez j'allais dire pour
vrai c'est à dire vous avez tous les
deux un travail vous mettez un peu en
disponibilité chaque semaine pour pour
faire votre assumer votre mandat de
maire entre est encore vous n'êtes pas
en retraite
c'est une idée fausse n ya pas tendre
traité que ça j'ai vu le alors monsieur
vous êtes vous vous travaillé comme
agent territorial au département du
doubs et vous madame vous êtes
enseignante donc dans un lycée agricole
enfin au cfppa de châteaufarine à
besançon alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que beaucoup as tu es tu
devenu quelque chose de bien clair mais
quelque chose de bien clair qui nous
garantisse aux droits à la retraite qui
nous garantisse d'avoir du temps qu'ils
soient faux qui compte de la même
manière que le temps travaillé c'est pas
le statut de l'élu
souvent à tort c'est perçu comme enfin
les élus réclament encore de l'argent a
en tout cas on va pas vous êtes malade
vous êtes payé l'un et l'autre
hasmonéens démouler vous êtes amené à
indemniser mario excusez moi dans le
vocabulaire
donc vous vous touchez a à peu près
mille six cents euros mary plus oui un
tricot et vous vous touchez 2000 euros
parce que la terre qu est un peu plus un
peu plus grande à l'intercours un peu
plus grande rue tout il y en a qui font
ça pour l'argent je crois pas ce qu'ils
font ça pour l'argent sont vite sans
vite déçus ou à mon avis sont vite
identifié parce que si on ne le fait pas
par conviction puis par par envie de
donner aux autres c'est pas la voilà
après c'est pas négligeable aux
indemnités sont sont quelque chose de
significatif
mais si on le fait pour ça mon avis ça
marche pas longtemps alors donc l'argent
on a parlé tout à l'heure ça vous mettez
du baume au coeur vous avez toujours
vous êtes toujours les lui préféré des
français donc il ya des indemnisations
et lui préférer président autre site de
reconnaissance et les indemnités
et puis il ya peut-être aussi des joies
quand même dans ce boulot à ben
heureusement qu'ils lui en arrivant il y
en a quand on célèbre des mariages fin
mais ça veut dire qu'on a des naissances
y ont noté des naissances sur nos
territoires ou un baptême républicain
donc ça ça fait partie on est quand même
dans des moments très intimes de la vie
nos administrés qui sont quand même des
moments de joie
il ya aussi pour moi les joies de voir
un certain nombre de projets enfin
arrivé au bout et donc et
réalisé et bénéficier aux administrés je
trouve que ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose vous voyez concrètement le boulot
que vous allez faire quoi que c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui nous motive
au contraire d'autres élus allaient les
députés tout allait débuter c'est vrai
qu'ils ont un rôle législatif et les
lois elles sont souvent leurs bonnes ou
mauvaises sont pas forcément comprise
par les par les administrés et puis
c'est très dur d expliquer par contre
réalisé des projets soutenus
personnellement moi c'est ce qui m'a
motivé parce que c'est aussi le coeur de
mon métier mais on a envie d'améliorer
l'environnement nos concitoyens parce
qu'on est aussi nous mêmes habitants sur
nos communes et on a envie d'offrir un
des meilleurs services une école une
belle place des belles rues de la
sécurité extérieure
ça c'est ce qui nous motive
essentiellement et quand on nous empêche
de le faire pour revenir sur ce que
l'état est un peu mode de façon
moralisateur d'inattention vous dépenser
trop eh ben ça nous frustre un peu parce
qu'on a l'impression de ne pas être
d'avoir les coudées franches et ça c'est
un permettant et il reste une minute je
voulais juste qu'on termine vous avez la
parole l'un et l'autre des conseils pour
ceux qui seraient tentés par le job vous
leur dites quoi à des gens qui se
présenteraient christelle clément tout
d'abord alors des conseils alors j'aurai
peut-être pas forcément la prétention de
donner des conseils en tout cas
je dirais qu'il faut continuer d'y
croire on a quand même on a quand même
une belle ruralité et qu on a encore la
possibilité de faire des choses
oui tout à fait on encore la possibilité
sérieuse moi j'irai alesi impliquez vous
dans la vie la vie citoyenne dans la vie
locale celle où vous allez pouvoir vous
n'êtes pas nourrir cela vous allez
pouvoir participer à des projets communs
pour la collectivité vous allez vous
sentir citoyen et essaie malgré tout
malgré des petits tracas ce très
épanouissant on n'est pas obligé d'être
mère on peut être adjoint ou simple
conseiller municipal veut travailler
dans les mêmes si on a besoin de soutien
et des souvenirs n'y a pas de souci
voilà merci madame merci monsieur merci
de votre attention et puis bon dimanche
après midi à tous au revoir
[Musique]